did you hear about that woman in florida
that
had um was it sea lions or manatees
that all jumped on top of her because
they thought she was another manatee
or something and they tried to have sex
with her i don't know why that just
reminded me of that
wait so a woman was raped by sea lions
because she looked like a manatee
the tourist on vacation went for a swim
near 2pm in the afternoon
when she was suddenly caught up by a
herd of male manatees
that possibly mistook the poor woman for
a female manatee right away that's
already tragic
tyler smith a 17 year old lifeguard
present during the sexual assault
believes she is lucky to be alive we
often
see manatees nearby but it's the first
time
that they wanted to have sex with
someone he admits there were so many
manatees around her
i think i counted at least 10 of them
they were all fighting against each
other to get
on her back and and humper it was like a
big manatee gangbang she's definitely
lucky to be alive he acknowledges
although experts claim this is
unprecedented and you said what did you
say about the manatee vagina is the same
as the human vagina jackie
yeah a manatee call alex back he's the
one who told me this my brother
that a manatee's vagina is the most
similar
to a female's vagina now it now it
bothers me even more that that's
with your brother your single brother
that's why he's he's okay with being
single
and he's oh no that's the last we talked
to me when that's a sea lion i'm looking
for a manatee because i want something
closer to the real thing that's not true
i'm gonna call alex back what animal is
he might have been lying hi
one more question yeah
does a manatee have a vagina
yeah it's actually one of the most real
it actually is the most realistic to a
human vagina
why do you know that who doesn't know
that
me who doesn't know that who doesn't
know that
everybody listening to this podcast
right now
a sheep is second to a manatee actually
is that true
yeah in the order of
so the uh jackie was telling us a story
about a manatee that was gang banged
that a lady that was gang banged by
manatees
yes yes you know that story yeah
right in florida duh wow in florida i
think when something strange happens if
you always say in florida that's a game
we play
but thank you for your insight into this
okay bye alex
can we have can we have a segment on
this podcast where it's just
animal facts from alex from my brother
alex mandel
i don't know if you were listening to
the podcast up until now we we've we
just had it
so it is a good idea but we just had
that
yeah okay this is not what i imagine
this podcast was going to be like when i
signed up to do a podcast with my father
me either